Recall that according to president Donald
Trump, Hillary Clinton could not be trusted
to handle sensitive secret and classified
information.
We've now learned that random guests at Donald
Trump's Florida resort Mar-a-Lago knew more
about the plan to assassinate Iranian leader
Kaseem Sola Mani then did our own members
of Congress.
According to a new report, Congress was not
informed of the administration's planned military
attack on a Solemani our European allies.
As I told you yesterday, we're not informed
per the daily beast.
During the days leading up to the assassination
of Solemani, Trump started to drop quote hints
to close associates and club goers that something
huge was coming and quote specifically mentioned
he'd been in close contact with his top national
security and military advisors on gaming out
options for an aggressive action that could
quickly materialize.
Donald Trump was reportedly walking around
his club Mar-a-Lago in Florida saying he had
a big response planned to Iran that people
would be reading about it quote very soon,
and meanwhile he was tweeting about Iran having
to pay a big price.
He kept saying, you'll see one of the sources
recalled describing a conversation with Trump
days before Thursday strike.
Totally cool.
Totally legal.
A totally responsible thing for a president
to do.
Random people at Mar-a-Lago had more of a
hint that something was upcoming on Iran,
a bigger hit than the gang of eight had in
Congress.
Nevermind.
The total lack of congressional authorization
that Trump claimed presidents needed back
when Trump wasn't president and Barack Obama
was.
It is absolutely unconscionable that the moral
Lago thing has been allowed to continue, but
why wouldn't it?
There have been no consequences to anything
that Donald Trump does.
If you want access to Trump, you can get it
by signing up for a membership at Mar-a-Lago,
$200,000 initiation fee, $14,000 a year in
dues.
This is a direct funnel of money from people
to Trump's businesses for access to the president
of the United States, even to a front row
seat of Trump, mishandling sensitive national
security information.
But we don't have to worry because it's don't.
He's donating his $400,000 salary, so it's
all fine.
People whose names we don't even know get
to hear from Trump about sensitive plans.
While my taxpayer dollars and your tax payer
dollars are funneled into Donald Trump's club
for security rooms, for Trump staffers, rooms
for secret service, golf cart rentals, shrimp
cocktail for Donald Trump.
If I were a foreign diplomat, I would immediately
just sign up for a Mar-a-Lago membership.
It's not an extravagance.
It's a geopolitical investment at this point
in time.
Why do you think the initiation fee doubled
at Mar-a-Lago from $100,000 to $200,000 after
Donald Trump was elected president?
This is profits hearing, but it's profiteering
that puts national security at risk and it's
profiteering on the basis of president of
the, of a president of the United States,
uh, essentially selling access to himself
at his club.
It's happening blatantly is happening boldly
and there are actually suggestions that the
stock trades of Mar-a-Lago members should
be investigated to look for patterns and see
if there's evidence of insider trading on
the basis of Donald Trump saying things while
roaming the halls.
Is this the type of winning we were told we
would get under president Donald Trump.
This is a red alert danger.
And after our interview, I am going to talk
about, we increasingly need to be putting
the pressure on Republican elected officials
who are unwilling to deal with this.
Trump is horrible.
The people around him are horrible.
There's no question about it.
But we talk about, Oh, we might need 65 or
70 million votes to remove this guy in November
of 20 2020 Republicans could do it, 14 cabinet
members could do it, and we'll talk about
that a little bit later.
In the meantime, it makes sure to vote in
our poll about what you think will happen
in Iran.
Follow the David Pakman show on Instagram
at David Pakman show, and while you're there,
follow me on Instagram at David dot [inaudible]
quick break and much more coming up to death,
t